-(AUDIENCE CHEERING, APPLAUDING)
-Hi, CNN.
We've missed you
these last five months.
Great to be back.
I'm here with editor-at-large
of Reason magazine, Matt Welch,
and senior editor
for The Dispatch , Sarah Isgur.
Okay, Sarah. "Which one
of the Trump indictments
do you think is the strongest?"
Oh, there's so many
to choose from.
(AUDIENCE LAUGHING)
But it's a really easy question.
It's the Florida case about
the classified documents
in the obstruction side.
You'll notice Trump
and his allies never talk
about that one.
The other cases
are all much weaker
in a variety of ways,
but that Florida case...
So, this is the one where
he took classified documents
-and put them by the toilet.
-Yeah, yeah.
-(BILL MAHER LAUGHING)
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING)
-You know--
-Why is that such a strong case?
It's after he's president.
There's just no real
legal defense to, you know,
even if you're
really constipated,
needing those documents
by your toilet...
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING, APPLAUDING)
-(LAUGHS) But...
I know what they're gonna say,
which is,
"Biden did the same thing,
he had papers by his Corvette."
He didn't defy a subpoena
-and then he lied about it.
-BILL: That's true.
I know that. I'm just saying.
He's not charged
with having the documents
or taking the documents,
he's charged with not giving
the documents back
when the government was like,
-knock knock, "Can we have
our documents back?"
-BILL: Right.
-And see...
-"What documents?"
...this is what I mean
when I always say,
-he's stupid and crazy.
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING, APPLAUDING)
They're... (LAUGHS)
They're stupid like I think
Frederick Douglass
is still alive.
(AUDIENCE LAUGHING)
The stealth bomber
is literally invisible,
you know, healthcare is,
no one knew it was complicated.
-Those are stupid.
-(AUDIENCE MEMBER LAUGHING)
Crazy is this. It's just crazy.
It's just a crazy,
unforced error.
Why do it?
He wasn't even looking at them.
It just was... "They're mine."
-Yeah? That...
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING, APPLAUDING)
And then when they came
and asked for the documents,
and he said no,
and then they tried
to move the documents,
then he realized
that was on camera
and so then he told the guy
to flood the server...
-I mean it was like, every step.
-(BILL LAUGHING) Okay.
"Nikki Haley rose
in the polls this week."
-Oh, good for you.
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING)
Nine to ten percent. Nailing it.
-(LAUGHS) Is that what it is?
-(SARAH ISGUR CHUCKLES)
"Are there enough
establishing voters
in the Republican party for her
to become a serious revival,
revival to Trump?"
-"Revival?"
-(MATT WELCH) Rival. Rival.
-Rival.
-BILL: Rival. Oh, okay.
Well, we're doing this
on the fly, you know.
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING)
-Rival to Trump, yes.
-Oh, hell no.
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING)
-(BILL LAUGHS) Okay. No?
-(AUDIENCE APPLAUDING)
There's actually
a really interesting poll,
I recommend people look
at the people at fair vote
who do ranked-choice voting.
They had a poll that basically
did ranked-choice
with the candidates,
a national poll,
and so each time around
you kick someone off the island
and then see how it goes
until you get to only two left.
And Donald Trump got
like 47 percent or something
in the first vote, first round.
And then, you know,
Doug Burgum goes
and Mike Pence goes,
bop, bop, bop, bop, bop.
He doesn't go up
even a little bit.
Turns out 47 percent
of Republicans really want
Donald Trump
to be the president,
and he was also number 13 by...
(CHUCKLES) ...the most people.
-(BILL LAUGHS) Oh.
-Like, he was last place.
Like, please anybody
but Donald Trump.
He only, like,
gets over the majority
when everybody else
is wiped out.
Nikki Haley does very well
in that poll.
She comes in second
once you start
knocking off Chris Christie,
and all these
semi-establishment people.
She will, she has the ability
maybe to look,
to get some people
who want to vote for Trump,
but the only way to get to
the Republican nomination is--
and this is why Ron DeSantis
still has a chance,
although he's
absolutely nosedived
during this calendar year,
is that people
who like Ron DeSantis
also like
Donald Trump sometimes.
He can straddle that.
Nikki Haley hasn't
quite shown that,
and the rest of them
have no chance.
She has really been
across the board, though.
I remember when the rumor was
that they were having an affair.
-(SARAH CHUCKLES)
-Remember that?
It was in the first Trump book.
-Do you remember that?
-SARAH: Yeah, I mean--
-No, I didn't
ever believe it either...
-(CHUCKLES)
...but she's gone from that
to I wouldn't even have her
on the ticket.
Look, I worked
for Carly Fiorina in 2016
and we're seeing
the exact same problem
that we saw then.
You can't have this
many candidates in the field.
-That poll,
which was fascinating...
-Yeah.
...actually showed in the end
that Ron DeSantis
could beat Donald Trump
by three points.
If it were only
the two of them in the race.
Right. Well, okay,
so was anyone surprised
that Donald Trump...
(SIGHS) Boy...
-MATT: No.
-...it's hard to... (LAUGHS)
-(LAUGHS)
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING)
-SARAH: Next question.
Next question.
-(LAUGHS)
-Keep going. (LAUGHS)
-(AUDIENCE APPLAUDING)
Wait a second.
"Leaked intel." Oh, I read this.
"On our nuclear
submarine program
to an Australian businessman."
You know what, I'm the last guy
to defend Trump.
This sounds like BS to me.
I mean, he, of course,
he does a million things
that you shouldn't do,
but leaked intel on
our nuclear submarine program.
I doubt if he knows
the first thing
-about our nuclear su--
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING)
-And I--
-(AUDIENCE APPLAUDING)
You know, I don't think
he gave away technical secrets,
which he was just bragging,
you know, "Our submarines."
And I'm kind of glad
that it gets around the world
that we can kick your ass.
(BOTH LAUGH)
This is the problem
where you think Trump
is like evil and stupid, like,
it's kind of one of the other.
-Like he's an evil genius.
-No. Crazy and stupid.
Not yours, I'm just saying
other people.
Like, you can't believe
he's like the super genius
who knows everything about
our nuclear subs,
-but also...
-Right. (LAUGHS) Right.
...he's a moron
who like doesn't know...
-Right, exactly.
-...like left and right are.
-It can't be both.
-Right. Okay, all right.
-"What is the--"
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING)
"What is the panel think
of California Governor Newsom
repealing the law that
banned doctors from sharing
unapproved COVID information?"
Well, of course, I love it.
They should have never done
in the first place.
(AUDIENCE LAUGHING, APPLAUDING)
Doctors should be able
to speak freely.
The media should be
the watchdog of what's going on
in the government,
not the megaphone,
not the amplifier of it.
I can't believe
you brought up this case,
'cause I'm really obsessed
with this idea that Newsom
and DeSantis are actually,
you know, different sides
of the same coin when it comes
to civil liberties,
-like free speech.
-BILL: Right.
Newsom is banning doctors
from saying something
about COVID that he doesn't
personally believe to.
-BILL: Well, now he's not.
-Okay, well,
Corden joined him first,
so, you know, okay.
And at the same time, you know,
DeSantis down in Florida,
is telling teachers
that they can't, you know,
teach certain things
at universities.
Like, how about just
the First Amendment?
-I'm pro that.
-BILL: Yeah.
-(AUDIENCE APPLAUDING)
-MATT: I also say that--
Gavin Newsom wanting to run
for president is the best thing
that could happen
to Californians.
(AUDIENCE CHEERING, APPLAUDING)
'Cause he'll make
a better governor that way.
-I'd say the same thing.
-MATT: Yeah.
I think he's a great politician.
I've been trying to get him
to run for president
-for 15 years.
-(MATT LAUGHS)
It would force him to go to the
center like this kind of stuff.
And that brief
I mentioned at the Supreme Court
right now wants to, like, have
a different homeless policy.
Like, he's moving to the center
on all sorts of stuff.
And he can win. You know what?
It doesn't hurt
to have a dreamy candidate.
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING, APPLAUDING)
-I'm not-- I feel it doesn't.
-(AUDIENCE CHEERING, APPLAUDING)
-I'm sorry.
I don't know.
That bear skin rug photo,
like, really weirds me out.
-BILL: The what?
-The-- (LAUGHS)
-BILL: What photo?
-The photo with him...
-MATT: Kimberly Guilfoyle.
-...and Kimberly Guilfoyle
where he's like
on the bear skin rug
and it's like really--
I don't know. Not my type.
-What can I say?
-BILL: All right.
-(LAUGHS)
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING)
"Should the Senate have loosened
the dress code to allow
for John Fetterman's shorts
and casual attire?"
-No. This--
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING, APPLAUDING)
That-- I mean,
that was so ridiculous.
I mean, I can't-- What is this
with John Fetterman?
Come on, man.
If you haven't seen it,
he looks like Kevin Smith.
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING)
-Remember Kevin's,
the hockey shorts in the Senate?
I mean, what is it?
What point is this making?
What is the point of this?
I never got it.
I'm so torn between my hatred
of rules and institutions...
-(BILL LAUGHS)
-...and my hatred
of inappropriate--
or people who dress like me
on weekends being in the Senate?
That's bad. We don't want people
who look like me.
I know. I just feel
it was such a stunt.
It's like, oh,
I'm the man of the people.
But you know what?
You know what
the people actually have to do?
-Dress.
-Yeah, for work.
Yeah. Dress for work. All right.
It gives you
some of that luxury good stuff.
This idea that you're a man
of the people.
-He comes from an incredibly
privileged background.
-BILL: Right.
He's never, like,
been faced with being fired
for not wearing something right
to work and then,
-you know, that's what you get.
-BILL: Well...
The people who are always going
on about privilege
always have the privilege
to be impractical
-in every possible way.
-(SARAH CHUCKLES)
But we gotta go. Thank you, CNN.
We'll see you next week.
(AUDIENCE APPLAUDING, CHEERING)